Okay. My answer looks something like this.
I had to import minidom so we could use that,
and then we used a parse string for minidom,
which is what we used previously in lecture to parse the XML that were passed in in this parameter.
Then I used getElementsByTagName GML coordinates.
Sometimes if the XML is more complex, you can't just cheat
and find the one tag name that you're looking for,
but in this case we know there's only going to be one coordinates element
in a valid response, so we can just see if there's any element in here that has this tag name.
If we have that element, this should return True.
We're actually kind of going out on a limb here.
If this wasn't such a simple document, such a simple protocol,
I'd probably have to check to see are there childnodes?
Do those childnodes have values? That sort of thing.
I haven't done any testing that would suggest that. Just assuming it's all there it doesn't work.
What I do is if it's all there, we call a split, which splits on the comma to get the two parts--
the longitude and the latitude--and then we reverse them and return with latitude and longitude.
If we print our response, this is what we get.
Now if I were to change our XML a little bit--let's say we just get rid of the actual coordinate
from the sample XML I passed in--and run this, we get None as our answer.
That should work for now. Good job if you got that, and let's add this to our program.